I hear can police have confirmed that
several petrol bombs were thrown as a
migrant processing center in Dover a
statement released in the last few
minutes says Kent police was called as
11 22 a.m on Sunday the 30th of October
2022 to the viaduct in Dover officers
established that two to three incendiary
devices had been thrown into a home
office immigration premises
one minor injury has been reported the
suspect has been identified and located
or joining me now is guys Ivor Bennett
who's in Dover for us and I've heard
some serious developments coming in from
Dover what further details do we have
yeah so as you say the fire happened at
this migrant processing center which is
behind this big building behind me so
you can't actually see it
um but the processing center is pretty
much the first Port of Call for migrants
when they arrive here in Dover are
having crossed the channel it's where
their Asylum claims are initially
processed the incident happened around
20 past 11 this morning the fire has
been put out but as you can probably see
there's a lot of activity still here
Kent Fire and Rescue Services are still
here so are the police and we've also
seen a bomb disposal unit go in here is
now out of science but they're still
still here on the scene now details are
still quite scarce but what we know so
far is that a man was seen throwing
petrol bombs confirmed by police as two
to three incendiary devices petrol bombs
attached with fireworks at this border
border force center and it was seen by a
photographer for the Reuters news agency
and that photographer says that he saw
the man then kill himself at a petrol
station no not far from here just 200
meters in that direction across a bridge
here and as I say the incident happened
around 20 past 11 it's been confirmed by
the home office a spokesperson said we
aren't aware of an incident at Western
jet foil that's the name of this
processing center police are in
attendance it would not be appropriate
to comment further at this stage now
what we don't know of course is who this
man was his name nor his his motive or
his reasoning for this attack
um the ins the the the facility though
would have been very busy because there
have been already migrant arrivals today
and it comes only a day after 990
actually made the cross a yesterday and
so a lot of people would have been there
the police confirming one person has
been injured and these processing
centers have already been in the
headlines uh this week because an
existing one an established one at
Madison airport has been criticized this
week as being overcrowded and unsafe in
this incident whatever the reasons for
It Whatever the motives will only put
these processing centers in a brighter
spotlight